hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is the
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
thanks so much for being with us Biden's
remade America that's the focus of
tonight's
angle all right everyone you can't say
they didn't warn us there will not be
another foot of Wall constructed in my
Administration those who come seeking
Asylum we should immediately have the
capacity to absorb them keep them safe
until they can be heard should someone
who is here without documents and that
is his only offense should that person
be deported that person should not be
the focus of deportation we see what's
happening to almost every corner of
America the Biden Administration is
working hard and as fast as they can to
change the United States and they're
going to try to do it before the next
election left-wing Mayors claim that
they're upset by all this too many
migrants and maybe they are upset but
they're in on it too they're enablers
listen to Chicago's mayor Brandon
Johnson he almost sounds proud city
government is maintaining our efforts to
welcome and resettle Asylum Seekers here
in Chicago and we are making
progress in partnership with the state
we have successfully helped over 10,000
new arrivals to resettle in the area and
reunite with family and friends and
various places meanwhile the migrants
keep coming and coming and coming until
recently many were camped out in Chicago
police stations but most of those have
been removed and now many of those are
living outside now right now it's 20
degrees in
Chicago but the real feel is just yeah
nine the entire situation Court courtesy
of Joe Biden is a travesty and at some
point thousands by the way Chicago are
supposed to be relocated it to to an
area that is yet to be constructed
that's going to hold semi-permanent tent
shelters yeah but local reports reveal
there is confusion and significant
opposition to this massive migrant
project and all of this and more
explains why Johnson has a
28% approval rating and when they're not
stealing tax dollars for the city
services they get some of the migrants
are spending their free time stealing
yeah and then there's New York where
Winter's right around the corner and so
are the lines of migrants trying to get
into City shelters we continue to
receive anywhere from 2000 uh to almost
3,000 uh migrant Asylum Seekers a week
uh that is a continuous number that is
just not sustainable we stated it over
and over again here's a message for New
York stop Marching for Hamas and start
marching for actual border enforcement
contrary to reports the November 20th
incident was promptly addressed and
brought under control through the
leadership of the principal School staff
school safety agents and the
NYPD the teacher was not in direct
danger we have taken disciplinary action
against some of the
students and across the country and what
was once beautiful San Diego you should
have sent seen this place in 1990 by the
way when I live there they're dealing
with a huge influx of migrants 300
living at the San Diego Airport alone
how's this even allowed and others are
just loitering the number of migrants is
simply breathtaking the San Diego sector
alone has received more than
230,000 people this year that's a 30%
increase from the year before now
taxpayers are fed up especially those
who live along the border and and
immigrants themselves who came the right
way taxpayers in Denver are seeing their
schools overrun and overwhelmed by
migrant students without any English
language skills including many
illiterate in their native
language but now let's move to the
heinous migrant crisis in Arizona to say
that border agents in the Tucson sector
are stunned and overwhelmed is a wild
understatement they apprehended
58,000 in 4 weeks
alone it's so bad that the border patrol
there tried to keep the public in the
dark they announced that they were
pausing all Tucson sector border patrol
social media accounts to deal with the
surge Fox News did a big piece about it
now think about that I I think it's time
for the public to actually hear from
federal officials to explain how they're
going to stop the Badness but you don't
want the border patrol people to get the
word out all we get is a tweet with a
very very bad summary of what's
Happening here's what happened just in
the last week
15,300 apprehensions 117 pounds of
fentanyl how many will be could be
killed with that 78 Federal criminal
cases 17 rescues 14 human smuggling
events and three narcotics events
whatever those are now wait a second why
don't we ever hear from our DHS
secretary why doesn't he speak about any
of this well because he's too busy lying
the answer is quite clear and that is to
fix a system that everyone agrees is
fundamentally broken and we need
congressional action for the 12 million
people who are here in the United States
who have been contributing so
fundamentally to our country's
well-being there are our neighbors our
friends our fellow congregants uh they
provide our our Frontline workers oh
yeah like the migrant team
who was accused of brutally murdering a
homeless man in New York just
recently yeah they're
contributing but it's all necessary
collateral damage for the White House to
get to their big goal which is creating
an America that won't know our history
where our kids are going to be taught to
hate the history and also to learn that
they're just victims of Oppression in a
society run by people with white
privilege unfortunately that's what the
migrants are going to be taught if
they're going to public school so this
is Biden's America and if you're as
horrified as I am and watching all of
this do everything you can to defeat the
people in charge right now so we can
actually save this country and that's
the angle hey sea Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else